זה שווה ערך למספר השאילתות שאנחנו עושים לקופסה השחורה. בואו נראה אם שאילתה אחת בלבד
תספיק. הנה התוצאה. מדדנו את qubit 0 כאפס. אז זה היה
ערך הקלט x ואת qubit 1 כאחד, שזה היה ערך הפלט f של x. אז עכשיו אנחנו
יודעים ש-f של 0 שווה 1. אבל מה עם f של 1? פה הבעיה. ברגע
שמדדנו את המצב, הסופרפוזיציות קרסו ורק הצלחנו למדוד חלק אחד של הפונקציה עם
שאילתה אחת. זה לא אומר לנו את כל מה שאנחנו צריכים לדעת כדי לקבוע איזו פונקציה זו. היינו צריכים
שאילתה שנייה לקופסה בשביל זה. אז למרות שעקרון ההקבלה הקוונטית מאפשר לנו בו-זמנית
לגרום לקופסה השחורה לחשב f של 0 ו-f של 1, אין לנו גישה לשתי
התשובות. הקבלה קוונטית לבד לא מספיקה. האלגוריתם של Deutsch
מראה איך אפשר להשתמש בהקבלה קוונטית קצת אחרת כדי ללמוד על הפונקציה שבתוך הקופסה השחורה. לא
נוכל ללמוד בדיוק מה הפונקציה, אבל כן נוכל ללמוד משהו חדש עליה עם
שאילתה אחת שלא יכולנו עם מחשב קלאסי. בואו נתחיל בהסתכלות על טבלה של ארבע הפונקציות האפשריות
שלוקחות ביט בודד לביט בודד אחר. כאן אתם יכולים לראות ששתיים מהפונקציות f_sub_1 ו-f_sub_4 תמיד
מחזירות ערך יחיד ללא קשר למצב הקלט. אנחנו קוראים לשתי הפונקציות האלה
קבועות. f_sub_2 ו-f_sub_3 יחזירו אפס או אחד בהתאם
למצב של x. אנחנו קוראים לשתי הפונקציות האלה מאוזנות. האלגוריתם של Deutsch
קובע אם הפונקציה קבועה או מאוזנת על ידי כמה התאמות חכמות ל-circuit שהשתמשנו בו
קודם. הנה ה-circuit. הוא מתחיל בהכנת qubit 0 למצב 1 חלקי שורש
2 כפול 0 + 1 עם Hadamard כמו קודם ו-qubit 1 למצב 1 חלקי שורש 2 כפול 0 מינוס 1
עם gate NOT ואחריו Hadamard.
אז המצב המלא בנקודה הזו הוא כאשר זה המצב של qubit 0
וזה המצב של qubit 1. הכנת qubit אחד בצורה כזו במקום פשוט
להשאיר אותו במצב אפס מאפשרת לאלגוריתם להשתמש בהקבלה קוונטית בשילוב עם התאבכות כדי ללמוד
על פונקציית הקופסה השחורה. בואו נראה איך כשה-qubit-ים מוזנים ל-UF, ה-gate של הקופסה השחורה, כמה דברים יכולים
לקרות. אם הפונקציה קבועה, אז הקופסה השחורה תבצע פעולה כלשהי על qubit אחד לבד ללא קשר
למצב של אפס. במקרה הזה, מכיוון ש-UF לא נוגע ב-qubit אפס או
מתעניין במצב שלו בכלל, אז ה-Hadamard השני כאן פשוט מבטל את מה
שה-Hadamard הראשון עשה. ונמדוד את ה-qubit במצב אפס. בואו נסתכל על הפונקציה המאוזנת f_sub_2 כדוגמה כדי לראות
מה uf עושה למצב במקרה הזה. כש-x הוא אפס, f של x הוא אפס וכש-x
הוא 1, f של x הוא 1. תזכרו מה אמרתי לכם על ה-uf gate. הוא לוקח את qubit 0
כמצב הקלט x שלנו ומוציא f של x על qubit 1. בהנחה ש-qubit 1
התחיל במצב אפס. אז עבור הפונקציה הזו מה ש-UF עושה ל-qubit 1 תלוי
ב-qubit 0. אם 0 הוא אפס אז qubit 1 יישאר במצב אפס כדי לקבל f
של x שווה 0. אם qubit 0 הוא 1, הקופסה השחורה תפעיל gate NOT על qubit 1 ותשים
אותו במצב אחד. אז נקבל f של 1 שווה 1. זה בדיוק מה ש-gate CNOT עושה.
gate CNOT לוקח שני qubit-ים, qubit בקרה ו-qubit מטרה, והופך את
המצב של qubit המטרה אם qubit הבקרה במצב אחד. אבל הוא לא עושה כלום ל-qubit המטרה אם qubit
הבקרה במצב אפס. אז UF עבור F2 הוא פשוט CNOT על Q0 ו-Q1. ה-gate
CNOT לא יעשה כלום לאיבר הראשון כי qubit הבקרה במצב אפס. אבל באיבר השני, האפס
הזה הופך לאחד והאחד הזה הופך לאפס. ואם נוציא סימן מינוס כגורם משותף, נראה שהמצב של qubit 1
לא השתנה. אבל האיבר הזה קיבל סימן מינוס. אז המצב של qubit 0
הוא זה שבעצם השתנה. הוא עבר מלהיות 0 + 1 להיות 0 מינוס
אחד. כשאנחנו מפעילים את ה-Hadamard האחרון על qubit 0, זה משנה אותו למצב 1. אז אם הפונקציה בקופסה השחורה
היא f_sub_2, נמדוד אחד במקום אפס. מסתבר שה-gate UF עבור הפונקציה המאוזנת השנייה f3 הוא אותו
gate CNOT ואחריו NOT על qubit 1. ה-gate NOT האחרון לא משפיע על qubit אפס. אז כשהפונקציה
מאוזנת, נמדוד את qubit 0 במצב אחד בסוף ה-circuit. עכשיו אם לא עקבתם אחרי כל
הדברים האלה, זה בסדר. אני מציע שתעברו על זה לבד כדי לראות איך זה עובד. הנקודה העיקרית כאן היא מה
שקרה כשהפעלנו את ה-CNOT עבור שתי הפונקציות המאוזנות. qubit 0 שימש רק כ-qubit בקרה כדי לשנות
את המצב של qubit 1. אינטואיטיבית, אתם עלולים לחשוב ש-qubit 0 יישאר ללא שינוי. ובכל זאת, איכשהו
הפעולות שלנו על qubit אחד בעצם שינו את המצב של qubit אפס על ידי שינוי הפאזה היחסית בין שני החלקים של
הסופרפוזיציה שלו. התופעה הזו ידועה כמנגנון ה-phase kickback והיא
מאוד לא אינטואיטיבית כמו הרבה תופעות קוונטיות. בצורה מסוימת, אפשר לחשוב על מנגנון ה-phase kickback
כמו חתירה בסירה. הפעולה של דחיפת מים אחורה בעצם דוחפת אותך קדימה. בדיוק כמו שהפעולות על
qubit 1 בעצם משנות את qubit אפס. עכשיו אנחנו יכולים להריץ את האלגוריתם של Deutsch על
Qiskit. כאן אנחנו יכולים לבחור איזו פונקציה לשים בתוך הקופסה השחורה ובחרנו ב-F3. הנה
דיאגרמת ה-circuit של האלגוריתם ואנחנו יכולים להריץ אותו כמו קודם עם sampler primitive. נקבע את מספר
הדגימות לאחד בלבד ונראה מה אנחנו מודדים. במקרה הזה, מדדנו אחד.
אז אנחנו יודעים שהפונקציה הייתה מאוזנת, שזה אכן מה שציפינו כי הקופסה השחורה הכילה את הפונקציה f3. אז עם שאילתה
אחת בלבד, הצלחנו להבדיל בין שתי הקבוצות האלה של פונקציות.
לאלגוריתם קלאסי היה לוקח שתי שאילתות לקבוע את זה. זה מראה יתרון צנוע של מחשוב קוונטי
על מחשוב קלאסי לבד, אבל זה לא כל כך מרשים. רק אחד לעומת שניים. אבל האלגוריתם של Deutsch